-Ladies and gentlemen,
it is time for "Bad Signs."
Here we go.
-♪ Ain't we lucky we got 'em? ♪
♪ Bad signs ♪
-Now, these are pictures of
funny or weird signs
that you saw and sent in to us.
But these are all real signs.
This first one was
sent in by Jackie Avery
in Holliston, Massachusetts.
Hey, we love Massachusetts.
She was trying to find a quiet
place to eat her lunch at work.
-Oh, okay.
-Yeah, and spotted
this sign here.
It says...
-There you go.
-Could have just said,
"It's closed."
Yeah.
This next one was sent in by
Bob Riggins in Boise, Idaho.
He spotted this great deal
at his local gas station here.
It says...
It's not bad.
-That's not bad -- just 10%.
-It's only 10%. Yeah.
-90% good.
-This next one is from
Robin Rosenthal
in Stamford, Connecticut.
Stamford!
-Yeah.
-Hey, what's up?
She was shopping for
some Halloween decorations
and spotted this.
I think this is funny.
It says, yeah,
real skull is $3.94
Faux skulls are also $3.94.
-I want to get the real skulls.
-No, no,
you want the faux skulls.
-The faux one?
-Yeah, they're the same price.
-Yeah.
-This one lasts you longer
than the real skull.
-Yeah, 'cause the real one
will deteriorate
'cause it's real.
-This one's for, like,
"Hamlet" or something like that,
if you're doing Shakespeare.
-Yeah, this one's for, like,
goofy kids' stuff.
-Yeah, then you put, like,
candy in this one.
Look, it's selling more
than the real skulls.
-Right. It's almost all gone.
It's a real human skull
in there.
-This next one is
from Jason Riley
in Anaheim, California.
He spotted this while driving.
It says...
That's not bad.
That's the best kind of massage.
-I love the crawfish massage.
-I "gar-on-tee" it?
-Yeah, I "gar-on-tee"
it's cold and dry.
No, it's hot and juicy.
-This next one is from
Ruby Jones in Phoenix.
That's a good name.
-Yeah, Ruby Jones.
-Ruby Jones.
Phoenix, Arizona.
She parked her car in
a parking garage
and was trying to find a way out
and she found -- Look at this.
"Elevator."
-Well, close.
-Yeah.
Close enough.
-Yeah, Close enough. Stairs.
-Close enough.
Stairs, elevator.
What's the big deal?
-Want a skull?
[ Laughter ]
-This next one is from
Joe Collins
in Biloxi, Mississippi.
He was out for a walk
and spotted this sign here.
It says -- Can we zoom in on
the sign there?
"Invisible fence."
-Oh.
-Looks pretty visible to me,
but I'm glad the sign is there.
-It will fool the dog.
-Yeah, exactly.
-This next one is from
Beth Jackson in Washington, D.C.
She was going to pick something
up and spotted this sign here.
-Hmm.
-How do you even find this sign?
-Yeah. That had should be
special-made, right?
Nobody has that sign in stock.
-It looks like --
Yeah, no one made this.
This is a sign
you can buy from a --
-I need a sign that says,
"The front door
is around the back door."
-Yeah.
No, the back door is the front.
Oh. This is the back door.
The front door
is around the back.
There's an invisible fence,
so just be careful.
-I can't see the fen-- Oh, wait.
It's right there.
-Oh, there's a floating sign
that says, "Invisible fence."
What is it -- Is this floating?
-Wait. There's a fence here?
-Oh, this one's awesome.
This is great.
I always like looking at
the technology,
new toilet technology.
-You love new toilet technology.
-That's right.
This is from Cindy Klein in
Naperville, Illinois.
She was shopping for
a toilet in Home Depot
and saw this sign.
Look at this.
It says, "Flushes 7 billiard
balls in a single flush."
What situation...
-Six?
-[ Shouting indistinctly ]
The boss can't find out!
-[ Gulping ]
Swallow all these
billiard balls!
-Don't swallow
the billiard balls!
Flush them!
-I got to swallow seven of them!
No toilet can handle that!
-What are we gonna do with
the cue ball?!
Can't handle the cue ball.
-Yeah, can't get the
8 ball either.
-No.
-It's only seven.
-That's true.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cymbal crash ]
-It flushes
seven billiard balls.
-Yeah, seven billiard balls.
-You got to choose
which one, man.
-Yeah, 13 ball? I don't know.
-It's that "Squid Game," dude.
-Stripes, solids,
whatever you want.
You better hope it's a solid.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Oh, man, I ate a billiard ball.
I feel like an idiot.
-No.
-Yeah, I ate seven of them.
-Alright, now you should
feel like an idiot, maybe.
What is the first number ball
that came out?
-Oh, let's see. Oh, lottery!
Number 6!
[ Popping ]
-Number 2! Hey!
-Number 2 came out.
-It's a lottery.
-[ Popping ]
7, 6, 49.
-Don't touch it! Don't touch it!
-53. Sorry.
[ Laughter ]
-It's an 8.
-Oh, sorry.
-I apologize. It's a 3.
-Yeah.
-I know. Sorry. I went too far.
-Awful.
-Went too far.
That's disgusting.
-Awful.
-Awful type of humor.
-I apologize.
That is beneath me.
-Oh, my gosh. And above you.
-And above me, as well.
Last one is from Rodney Ames
in White Plains, New York.
He stopped at his
favorite coffee shop
to get some lunch
and saw this in the window.
"Open daily.
Closed Tuesdays."
There you go.
That's all the time
we have for "Bad Signs."
If you see a funny sign,
e-mail it to us at
badsigns@tonightshow.com.